in this video we want to compute what
833
divided by
seven is
so i encourage you to pause this video
and see if you can figure that out on
your own
all right now let's work through it
together and you might have appreciated
this is a little bit more difficult than
things that we have done in the past and
in this video i'm going to show you a
method that your parents have probably
not seen but you'll see that it's kind
of fun and it's called division with
partial quotients which is a very fancy
word but as i said it'll be fun
so the first thing i will do is i will
rewrite this as 833
divided by
divided by
seven
so you can view these as the same
expression the reason why we do it this
way is it formats it so it's a little
bit easier to do our division with
partial quotients
so wait the way that division with
partial quotients work and once again
it's not the way that your parents
probably learn how to do it is you just
say hey how many times can 7 go into 833
i don't have to get it exactly i just
want to go under 833
and so my brain immediately thinks well
700s is less than 833 so we're going to
go into 833 at least 100 times and so
what we would do is we would write that
100 up here we want to be very careful
about our place value you could view
this column as the hundreds column this
is the tens column this is the ones
column
and then we want to see how much do we
have left over how close did seven times
a hundred get us so what we do is we
multiply 100 times seven to get 700
and then we can subtract that 700 from
833 to figure out how much more we have
left and so 833 minus 700 is
133
and so we could then say all right we
still have another 133 to go so how many
more times can seven go
into this
well seven goes into 133 you don't once
again you don't have to have it exactly
if you know
see seven times 10
is equal to
70. actually let's go with that we know
we go at least 10 times so let's write
that up here we're going at least 10
times and to figure out how much more we
have left let's multiply 10 times 7 to
get 70 and then we can subtract
and we see
that
we have let's see 3 minus 0 is 3 13 tens
minus 7 tens is 6 tens so we have 63
left so 7 definitely can go into 63.
we're going to keep doing this until we
have a number less than 7 over here so
let's see 7 how many times does 7 go
into 63 you might know from your
multiplication tables that 7 times 9 is
63 so you could get it exactly so you
could just write that up here we have 9
more times to go into the number and
then you would say 9 times 7 is 63 and
you can say hey we got exactly there we
have nothing left over and as long as
this number is less than seven you know
that you can't divide seven anymore into
our original number
and so you're you're done and so how
many times does seven go into eight
hundred and thirty-three
well we said it go went a hundred times
and then we were able to go another 10
times and then we were able to go
another nine times and so what we want
to do is add these numbers so you want
to add 100 plus
10
plus
9.
when you add up all of them what do you
get
you get 9 ones 110 100 you get 119. so
this is equal to 119 all i did is i
added these up
now i want to be very clear that you
could do division with partial quotients
and not do it exactly like this that's
kind of why it's fun
so let's re let's do it another way so
let's say we want to figure out again
how many times does 7
go into
833 800 833
we could have said
maybe it goes 150 times so what you
could have said is you could have said
all right my current
guess or estimate is 150 times then i
could multiply 150 times 7. how would i
do that let's see 0 times 7 is 0.
5 times 7 is
35 you can carry the 3 so to speak
5 times sorry 1 times 7 is 7 plus that 3
is going to be 10 and so that gets us to
10 50. well over here we just finished
overshooting it doesn't go 150 times
there's nothing left over so 150 is too
high so we would want to backtrack that
and then you could go well maybe i could
go to 110. so let's try that out so
110 and now let's multiply 0 times 7 is
0. 1 times 7 is 7 1 times 7 is 7. so 110
times 7 is 770. so that works it's less
than 833 but let's see what we have left
so we subtract we get a 3 here and then
let's see 83 tens minus 77 tens that's 6
tens
and actually that got us there a lot
faster so then you could you could just
know that hey 7 goes into 63 nine times
but let's say we didn't know that we
could say all right let's say i'm going
to estimate it goes 8 times
so you would put an 8 up here and then
you say how much do we have left over 8
times 7 is 56
you subtract and then 63 minus 56
is exactly 7 and they say okay look i
can go one more time so i'd write that
up there and so 1 times 7 is 7 and then
you see we have nothing left over so we
are done so how many times did it go in
1 plus 8 is 9 plus 110 is 119.
so hopefully you find that interesting
and i really want you to think about why
this is working we're just trying to see
how many times can we go in without
overshooting it
and then what's left over so how many
more times can we go in and then what's
left over then how many more times can
we go in until what we have left over is
less than seven so that we can't go into
it any more times